the thing they should do i think i think
so um hey look here rachel bitkoffer has
a few um
gifts here
historic choice
a promise kept
judge contangi brown jackson very good
um uh if you need if you need some gifts
if you need some memes rachel's pumping
them out over there uh here's one uh
gop ran on rule broadband they ran on it
like they want it and it's because their
constituents need it like it's a thing
that is needed for americans not
regardless of their political beliefs
regardless of it now these people need
to deliver actual good rural broadband
so they can be connected to the rest of
america the only problem is is that the
gqp doesn't want them to have it
democrats delivered it because
republicans love to promise and destroy
they love that i mean fascists love to
promise and destroy like that's the
thing that they do that is the thing
they do so democrats delivered rule
broadband and it was great to see last
night
when joe biden brings this up
and they have to they have to figure out
are we supposed to clap for our
constituents getting broadband that we
ran on but but joe biden delivered how
do we do this what do we do oh my god i
can't i can't take it i can't take it
um so thank you rachel for your guest
speaking of rachel bitcover speaking of
rachel big governor
good morning rachel how are you
makes me happy you noticed all our uh me
and dougie's hard work yeah straight
back team you know
yes well i i i love i love the the gifts
and the memes that you guys come up with
it it really helps get uh the
messaging in front of people um i i
think i think we live in a meme gift
society right like a social media kind
of thing those small messages are
important and last night there was those
little small hints all the way through
the state of the union where joe biden
is saying the things that republicans
want to run on right like
it's it's so incredible to see
like just just the one instance of the
rule of broadband like you tweeted there
that that joe biden was able to say we
delivered rule broadband to you and and
he even said at one point i think he
said and you all and he looks over the
republicans and he's like and all of you
are out bragging to your constituents
about it like it was it was beautiful so
what did you think about the state of
the union what did you think about his
speech but more more realistically like
in the political body of things because
we are in a midterm cycle here what do
you think it means for the midterm cycle
and the messaging
i mean the speech was is different right
so two weeks ago that would have been a
fully domestic speech right right now
ukraine forced it i mean really it's
hard to write that's why you had to go
bullet like so fast right he had to go
fast because they had to rewrite that
speech a couple times um to deal with
the international focus it's very rare
that the state of the union has a large
international focus the last time of
course was in iraq when bush did the
axis of evil speech that ended up
[ __ ] up the middle east for years
right right
well i mean i mean really really it
changed the whole dichotomy of our
country i mean and how we look at war
and you know and and uh occupation
really like how do we occupy forever and
ever and ever is that called war do we
call it war does americans know we're at
war i mean it really changed that a lot
yeah and you know for me like i think
like i you know i watch it as an expert
i mean number one guys what you should
understand is i don't ha i didn't have a
cop i could have gotten the speech i
could have gone and looked at it but i
didn't [ __ ] need to okay i had all
those memes ready and i knew exactly
what was coming and the party could do
this [ __ ] too imagine
if there is actually a democratic
digital war room because there's
something called the dnc war room but
which which account was running a war
room last night mine or the dnc
right definitely mine right and i'm not
saying that to float my own [ __ ] boat
what i'm trying to say is we have to
we it's not going to be helpful just
have one woman with 126 000 followers
doing it you we all have to be running
on full cylinders and like that there if
i was in charge of [ __ ] that state of
the union night there would have been
surrogates going on the media all all
weekend to prep it all you know ukraine
would have changed a little bit but on
on tuesdays certainly and then you have
to have a full court branding offensive
on digital space you know and uh yeah
it's it's do you think do you think do
you think that that that kind of failed
that that they didn't get that messaging
across um that they just let it live in
the speech and not outside in more of
the aggregate and try to get the
messaging in front of people yes i mean
they're not gonna do that right right
well and that and that's and that's and
that's you know kind of what's up to us
right i mean like like twitter and and
people who think that who think that
quote unquote democrats messaging sucks
you're the democrats messaging you're it
like you can you can do this so like and
i'm making it easy on them tony i mean
here's the thing is like i was so
delighted that you were showing people
the activity of last night because
eventually very soon i'm gonna load up
um the whole toolkit on to the strike
pack website but right now it's
accessible on twitter and what i'm
trying to tell people is here's the
message go and get it in front of people
right and like when i lay out the
toolkit i'll i will put a guide out with
it right
but to give you kind of a preview of
that like my vision now is like okay
let's make a digital grassroots
like basically field team right and it's
one thing to be posting [ __ ] on your
twitter or like the people you follow
but what i want to teach people to do
is take these memes these ads that are
glance ads because that's what i'm
making there and these are not memes
these are glance ads okay right right
right and they are designed to get the
message even if the person doesn't want
to [ __ ] read it
see how that works like you get you read
that message even if you don't want to
see it right right and now it's about
eyeballs right so like i can make [ __ ]
all [ __ ] dead guys at the end of the
day and you know most of like our
miniscule budget has gone to creation
but my concern is distribution
distribution we're talking about
millions of dollars and right now i am
you know cockled out of the money system
of the democratic orbit because other
people are invested in ideas that i i've
argued have total merit in many
capacities but are not our best
uh source for winning in 2022 and the
texas turnout last night is a great
demonstration of that though i can
promise you
the gop did not outlook them two to one
on turnout because so many voters
couldn't vote okay right because
democrats don't give a [ __ ] right now
they don't know what's happening they're
not being told to be fearful and they
don't give a [ __ ] and you can see it
right in that data right and i'll tell
you guys there's a lot of better fans
and myself included right you cannot win
that race if you do not get a massive
enthusiasm push in texas because he's
got to convert he's got to convert right
leaning indies
and the way that you do that is not by
pretending to be a republican the way
you do that is by disqualifying the
opposition
okay
but he has to meet that with it's it's
the georgia formula you can't win in
georgia unless you can win the
conversion pool and the turnout game and
it's the same thing in texas
right so you see you think he can win
but it's it's a it's a it's uh
no not at all i would not right now guys
to be clear rachel is telling you the
truth okay
right now there's two indicators that
matter the generic ballot which when
people ask do you want republicans or
democrats to control congress in the
fall
and the enthusiasm advantage which is
how many people say they're very excited
to vote divided by party like breakdown
by party
and on both of those metrics we are
trailing
and if we continue to trail then they
will win 30 seats in the house and in 30
seats in the house are getting one
you're flipping michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin to gop hands for 2024 the
governorships and there's no way a state
like texas can flip but that said the
texas
florida arizona and georgia races to me
are a packaged messaging opportunity
here is what your life looks like when
republicans control it
they kill you they steal your [ __ ] they
poison your children
right
yeah that's so like there's a lot of
value and better because he's such a
great candidate and in like that
narrative being able to run through the
whole sun belt so to me this is still a
very valuable race it's not impossible
to win
but we can we're not winning [ __ ] unless
we deal with the generic ballot it
doesn't matter if it's florida [ __ ]
ohio with that nut job jd vance at the
end of the day guys we have an
electorate our side our coalition is not
engaged and we must must address it
so so you're saying we have to engage
the vote and that means engaging your
neighbors engaging people you know
talking to them showing this stuff
sharing this stuff and not just not just
in dms not just on twitter but when you
go to the grocery store when you're at
your church when you're at your
community talking about these things and
and knowing how to talk about them and
how the messages is wrapped around
because really honestly the the
republican party the gqp has handed us
this on a platter this win
i mean with with their with their
sycophantry to to putin and at the the
the murderous dictator that he is and
give serving that up on a platter that
that gives us more more fodder and to
show them exactly what they want for us
like oh you want the putin for us and
what does that mean for us what does
that mean for your broadband what does
that mean for your schools what is
that's right
right
they want to [ __ ] take your gay son
and put him in prison dude or kill him
right i mean that if you're aspiring to
putin's gay policy that's what that is
dude it's not there's no people in
russia because if you get caught being
gay your [ __ ] life is over right
right not what tucker carlson every
night is is is in
aspiring to on fox news right so like at
the end of the day yes you gotta reach
out to all of these other people the
what i call the marginal members of the
2020 2018 coalition and the message that
you give them can't be well they got you
some bridges and [ __ ] dude it's got to
be if you don't [ __ ] vote then
america as you know it will die and
these people are coming for you
right just like putin comes for other
people yeah i mean what what is what is
to say because donald trump the cheeto
dust mobster stands on stage and says
putin had such a great real estate deal
what a great deal two dollars of
sanctions and he got all this land and
he took this whole country and it's a
great thing and it's fantastic
what makes you think that they wouldn't
have that view of quote unquote a blue
state right what makes you think that
they they wouldn't occupy california
what makes you think they wouldn't
overthrow a democratically elected state
government in california or new york
what makes you think they won't do that
they aspire to be putin
tons more violent dude they've got [ __ ]
tons of guns they've been cultured to
see you as an animal me as an animal
yeah we are not even human beings
because of right wing media propaganda
so like dude i hate to tell you hippies
[Laughter]
well unless you see a future
in which
you know your kids can't [ __ ] eat you
probably want to vote
right and who is the people that that we
talk to because i think what you're
saying is people who don't normally
engage in politics right like me and you
are constantly me and you are constantly
involved in politics we're watching it
every single day every single move but
there are people out there that they
don't even know who the vice president
of the united states is they don't yeah
let me be clear tony we are we are one
percenters and anyone listening to this
podcast is a one percenter and even if
you get a million people
audience
there will be a one percenter and all
their all the people listening to you
will still be in that one percent
because 98 percent of the [ __ ]
country doesn't even know what nato is
if you ask them to define it maybe now
maybe after a week we could get to like
30
right right right they could figure out
they could figure out an explanation
that would result exactly and like
democrats want to do all this complex
nuanced like special drill down policy
[ __ ] i'm like dude they don't [ __ ]
know anything they don't know the
republican party has collapsed into
extremism they don't understand that the
entire republican tribus the party
conspired in a plot to steal the
election
in 2020 right and they're all under
federal and [ __ ] investigation for
they don't know any of this [ __ ] okay
right like what i'm trying to get people
to understand is our messaging should do
two things it should motivate and and
disqualify the other party right but it
should it has to tell our coalition what
is happening and what the stakes are in
the future for them
right right well and i think i think i
think we can manage to make that happen
but it is a big feat because there are
so many there's so many ears out there
to get this message into and not just
get it into but to get them to
understand in a way like you're saying
because this is this is kind of
um i i don't i don't bring out data here
we don't analyze you know a lot of stuff
on the show here we try to keep the
messaging very simple because i think i
think things are really simple like and
democrats want to use the phrase
universal pre-k and i'm like that's
ridiculous just say you want to start
school at age three instead of five like
that's so simple right there's things
that are so simple about when you're
talking about these things well we
universal healthcare what a dumb phrase
that is you just don't want to go broke
because of a medical bill like your
chick yeah and tony i mean here it is
like so like when uh when i when i hit
espn radio like i want to hit all the
sports radios right and what i'm going
to do with it is real [ __ ] simple
it's not complex at all i'm going to say
hey you don't do sports betting without
looking at stats why in the [ __ ] do you
vote that way right right right that's
why that's the whole ad except for the
f-bomb right well because the truth is
those people who don't know what nato is
they know the exact inflation rate that
is supposed to be on the football
because tom brady
they're all capable of knowing it right
you know our culture
our civic culture is the re i mean at
the [ __ ] core of what's going on here
is this is this american public that
decade after decade has been cultured to
think politics is disgusting
and i'm morally superior by not
participating in it
right i mean that's what we teach people
have you ever met anyone and you ask
them this about politics or oh i don't
vote and then there's right about it
like you're some kind of insect because
you [ __ ] maintain your own government
right right but that's because i'm just
leaving on them i'm blaming it on our
culture right right cultural socio
like culture
phenomena in america and it tells people
you should have the right to have all
this privilege with no responsibility
and in fact don't even look over here
because it's icky
terrible well and
so if we unwind that a bit because that
that is an interesting observation and i
like that observation that it is the civ
civic culture that we have to not
participate in things like politics but
to participate in things like
uh sports professional wrestling and it
almost seems like
that at the point when donald trump
entered the race as this clown and this
reality star that he was able to engage
some of those populations that that
didn't participate in that in that civic
culture and he created this own
different reality of civic culture like
they believe these things that aren't
even close to being true because somehow
that got engaged and
there's even more complicated things
where like in georgia in the runoff for
the senate runoff he was able to
convince a lot of his voters that hey
it's rigged anyways like like democrats
have done for years like oh it's i can't
you can't win a red it's a red state my
vote doesn't count so why should i vote
you know like even if i wanted to vote
you know those kind of yeah and they'll
have that mentality tony sitting in one
of the most competitive house races in
the [ __ ] country right
right right like they won't even know
like they're like sitting in georgia six
but they're like oh not georgia whatever
idaho six and it's like oklahoma or
whatever it's it's the red state but
they're in a competitive race and they
should be voting you know at the state
legislative level and we don't we don't
do any of that education they have i
mean i just come back from the church
for the kirk show right like that hasn't
aired yet and maybe it will never air
but if it does like people are gonna see
this turning point found place that i
went to tony i [ __ ] you not it's sitting
in one of the most expensive lots in
phoenix in tempe arizona
and they have three
different
large office structure buildings all
devoted to turning point and that
turning point usa by the way is charlie
kirk's organization which focuses on
converting college kids into
ideologues
and like his staffers in there they were
flying all around the us okay because
it's all financed by the tune of
billions of goddamn dollars and i can't
find one [ __ ] person to write a check
and let us shore up the democrats weak
sauce [ __ ] effort in 2020
right so so let let's talk about that
for a second because um you did you did
record with charlie kirk right is that
yeah yeah sure
and and
so they haven't given any indication
whether that is going to release or not
i i take it i take it rachel uh
bitcoffer ate charlie kirk's lunch a bit
i would maybe that's why they won't
release it you can
i don't know we'll see
right i mean i want it to be released so
that should tell you something right
[Laughter]
but what you're describing what you're
describing is uh one
this isn't the republican national
committee right this isn't the the party
this is a organization outside that uh
just one of them and you're saying that
they have floors and floors
they have floors
floors and floors in three structures
you can google map this [ __ ] turning
point usa headquarters in tempe phoenix
i'm sure you can [ __ ] see it dude
right and that is and that is not the
rnc but they coordinate with the rnc
it's all centralized the messaging's all
centralized right and we don't have a
goddamn thing like that dude right
so so moving towards that i mean
do do you see the democrats creating
something like that because i cuz cpac
cpac was last weekend right and and and
charlie
tarry kirk's turning point usa has their
own cpac type thing right why don't
why don't democrats have a cpac title to
be clear there's no one in charge of the
democratic party there's people in
charge of various institutions and they
run bureaucracies okay they don't run
electoral strategy there is in my
opinion no brain trust for this party
but if there was and i was in charge of
it tony i can guarantee you the first
[ __ ] thing i'd be doing is
copying alec
the american legislative exchange
council which is the the outfit that
gives them all their model ledge okay
and then i would turn our model ledge
into wedge [ __ ] and i would put that
[ __ ] in steam legislatures and [ __ ]
drive drive drive enthusiasm the way
they do without
right um and the second thing i would do
is is judicial watch because that's a
conservative thing for the courts and
its main purpose over the years has been
to poison american public opinion
against the supreme court and to see it
no matter its mix as a liberal
you know um radical institution even
when even when it's not even close to
that and they're still talking about
that like they'll get one fate one
disfavorable decision and judicial watch
and all of these organizations pop and
so we need the courts we need a
federalist society too to go with that
so we've got a robust law school program
that is encouraging kids to
to not fall into this trap with the
federalist society and then you know and
and of course the war room we need a war
room with a small cabinet a general with
autonomy and authority and we need to
start centralizing our ship right now or
we're going to lose that generic ballot
and enthusiasm fight and if we're losing
that in september then i don't even need
to stick around for the election frankly
do you do you think if if the democrats
can manage to put together some
infrastructure and and i you know like
you said before i think the
infrastructure lives there it just
there's no connection between it right
there's no
it's all there it's just not there there
right so it's how you talk about it
right so like i i worked with one group
and they sent me a copy of something and
i love that they were using democrats
deliver right
everybody should be using that every
chance they get whenever they're talking
about any credit claiming topic but
anyway you know the first version was
democrat you know this was their first
revised version and it was democrats
deliver
you know safe roads and bridges and
water and i'm like that's good because
now it's short and someone's going to
see it right
has to be like a glance message to be
able to see because most people are only
going to read it they're going to take
it out of the box they're going to see
it's political junk mail and they're
going to throw it back and glance it and
but i wrote back and i was like but you
can still be better and let me tell you
how
democrats deliver
roads that don't crush your spouse on
the way home from work right right water
that doesn't poison your children that's
it that's right you gotta make the image
right right give an image and i gotta
tell you you know i i'm trying to [ __ ]
myself out as much as possible to help
people with messaging to refine messages
to make them more valuable but it's not
going to replace a position where i can
actually force a wall operation in these
competitive races right and those
competitive races at those 30 that you
were saying earlier because that's
really where the rubber meets the road
because and we don't know exactly what
30 right at this point because some of
those races haven't developed but
there's you know what you're saying is
30 races there's maybe 30 seats at stake
here that could that could put us in a
position where we don't want to be where
they're they're talking because let's be
frank if they get those 30 seats they're
not putting kevin mccarthy a speaker of
the house
that's not what's happening and even if
they do i mean is kevin gonna stand up
for democracy clearly not right right
right
manages to survive that right the what
will happen in the house is catastrophic
right and like in virginia when duncan
took over what he did is catastrophic
okay right within his confines of he
doesn't control the one chamber that
wasn't up for election that cycle
thank god right
but he's got a couple democrats who are
gone full apologetic democrat and
they're joining the republican coalition
to overturn all kinds of [ __ ] okay
and you have to
you have got to let the voters know this
is the change that you're signing up for
are you sure this is the kind of change
you want
right right
to jump today tony i'm so sorry i gotta
no that's okay that's okay i i
appreciate you joining us and coming
here like all day five days a week and i
can't wait
to see how the show takes off
we got we've got big news next week i i
know it's it's going to be big and i
think everyone's going to love it and i
hope to have you back next week and
we'll talk about that more rachel you
have a good day and
make sure you send uh uh that uh you
give us the link for the the toolkit and
yeah it's not up yet guys it's something
that me me and my my little uh padawan
are gonna be getting together now that
we've got a good amount of content to
get out there and then i'm going to
write up a little guide like
indivisible's guide for organizing
grassroots it will be rachel did coffers
guide to you know setting a referendum
narrative against the republican party
because no one else is going to [ __ ]
run against the republicans guys if we
don't do it for the democrats let's do
it let's get our message out there and
let's keep pounding rachel uh audience
stick around we'll be right back thanks
rachel have a good day see ya see you
soon
we'll be right
back mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast